elon musk it looks like he's going to
get the deal done elon musk went out on
april 14th and he said that he was going
to buy twitter for 54 and 20 cents a
share about 43 billion dollars now this
was right after he'd spent about 3
billion personally to go ahead and
purchase about nine percent of the
business he became the largest
shareholder and everyone said what's
going on the world's richest man he's
getting in the game twitter obviously
came forward and tried to get him to
join the board of directors but elon
said i ain't joining the board of
directors on april 14th he said i made
an offer and he put out a link to the
sec filing now this morning at 9 12 a.m
the most legitimate source on the
internet breaking 9-1-1 said twitter set
to accept elon musk's original 43
billion offer according to reuters now a
lot of people are wondering why is the
richest man in the world trying to buy
twitter well it's because he says that
he wants to preserve freedom of speech
he says he doesn't care about the
economics of the deal everything got way
more serious when they realize the guy
who's tweeting out memes about bill
gates and other things he's not just
trying to buy twitter as a media stunt
he actually has the money why elon musk
went and he got 46 billion dollars of
funding some of its equity capital he's
putting up some of it comes from morgan
stanley and other lenders but he got the
cash and nobody else had the money or
the appetite to buy twitter twitter had
no other suitors it's just elon with his
46 billion dollars pulling a stare down
with the twitter board of directors and
so what is he going to do once he goes
ahead and buys twitter well he's got
this tweet here where he says that his
number one thing that he's going to
focus on is that he wants to defeat the
spam bots or he's going to die trying
and guess what there's lots of people
who they don't like the idea of the
world's richest man actually buying
twitter and so they're all talking about
how they're going to delete their
accounts our boy joe here had a great
tweet
he said you can find me on instagram at
vlogmas his twitter is the new i'm
moving to canada if donald trump becomes
president no you're not
stop virtue signaling on the internet if
you really thought that you were gonna
move to canada you should have done it
if you really think you're gonna stop
using twitter go ahead we won't miss you
so ultimately what we're going to watch
here is it looks like twitter's going to
accept this offer and elon musk is going
to get his hands on what i personally
believe is one of the most influential
pieces of technology in the world
now the theory that elon could be buying
twitter simply because it's the
marketing department for tesla and it
preserves his ability to continue to
market tesla it's pretty interesting but
i think it's probably more likely that
he simply saw the opportunity for a
company that was in distress that didn't
have its way and imagine if you're the
ceo of this business you step in you've
been there for less than six months and
already you've got somebody who has
raided the company and it's gonna take
it over and fire your ass he's almost
bullying the twitter board right he said
i'm going to buy twitter they said we're
going to do a poison pill make sure you
can't buy twitter it goes cool i'm still
going to end up buying twitter by offers
he's straight up putting their heads in
a toilet game of swirly and then he's
sitting there and he's going back to the
teacher and he's like i'm still a good
guy so the only thing i think about if
twitter is one of the most influential
and important things for free speech is
it that great that he's going to take it
private yes why why is that like so much
better because they don't have to answer
to shareholders right so every every
quarter now he has to do these calls
right and it's public markets his
stock's going to trade a lot it's more
volatile you have to answer to a bunch
of more people now he's going to be able
to do all these things in private
without having to answer to other people
for sure but the volatility of the
company isn't going to change on a
day-to-day basis yeah but i think that
answer to other people kind of keeps
them in check a little bit rather once
you take it private you can well here
here's what i know they've been a public
company for almost a decade and they
ain't got no free speech anywhere you
could you couldn't find free speech if
you spent 10 years looking for not only
these morons are taken down they're
still literally satire websites that
have been taken down
think about this for a second the
president of the united states got taken
off the platform but vladimir putin's
still on there the ccp has
state-sponsored media still on the
platform i don't want to hear [ __ ]
about we protect free speech
because they are literally the digital
version
of just like the the uh uh what they
call um uh the killing squad where they
just line people up and just shoot them
because they disagreed with their views
that's literally what twitter does
they don't commit violence they don't do
any of that stuff but what they
essentially are trying to do is they are
trying to silence voices that they
disagree with
and i think that we're better off
playing a game where we say
i want somebody in charge who cares
about free speech i get everyone's like
oh there should be no owner like yeah of
course
the ideal world would be there be no
owner and there'd be no rules life would
be amazing right maybe i don't know but
i do know that right now the current
setup is about
as close to bad in the public markets as
you could get
we're literally if i tweet
i get more replies from spam bots than
anything else
like you got to be an idiot if you work
at twitter you can't solve this problem
right now i could solve the problem i
don't even write code give me two
engineers we'd solve the problem in a
couple days guess what we do if you
tweet and immediately it says any of
these 10 keywords nukem
right that would get rid of 20 of the
spam second thing is if every time
somebody tweets there's an immediate
response from the same [ __ ] account
with your profile picture yeah newcomb
all right that's now we're down to forty
percent of the spam says great deal here
yeah newcomb now we're down to fifty
percent of the spam got right it's not
hard
and again people are like oh what do you
know like no literally i worked at a
company and that is part of the problems
of what we dealt with like i know
exactly what the problems are right and
so ultimately i think that you could
take elon musk he's going to walk in
there the number one thing that elon's
going to be able to do that they can't
do right now at twitter
right and i want to make something very
clear there's some great people who work
at twitter who work their asses off and
they're trying to do the right thing
they say you just the leadership is not
allowing them to do the things that they
want to do right and so ultimately what
i think is going to happen here is elon
musk is going to walk in there he's
going to he's going to have open season
he just did with neurolink the other day
he did it with boring company
if you're the best in the world at this
[ __ ] come help us
and guess what they're going to do they
have a line out the door people want to
go work for elon musk at twitter
right hundred percent yeah and those
people are gonna show up and they're
gonna say they can't get rid of the spam
bots
give me two days right and then you're
gonna see the bots go away and they're
like we can't grow
give me a give me three quarters right
and then all of a sudden you're going to
see growth come back then they're going
to go problem by problem by problem by
problem and it's just classic
complacency that's all that's going on
there right now and if you get the best
people in the world to go work there and
elon who he's not joking around we
talked about last week when they decided
they were going to create the boring
company he said how long will it take to
uh create a hole and they said two weeks
he said how about today on friday we
start right now and we go until sunday
24 hours uh a day and let's see how far
we can get and within two hours they
were in the parking lot they already and
they'd already broke uh broke into the
ground they were digging
so think about that like the sense of
urgency they sounded like [ __ ] two weeks
right now
go outside right now and start digging a
hole
and by the way you got till sunday see
how far you can get
if he walks into twitter i promise you a
bunch of people are going to claim that
they're going to quit they're not going
to quit but they're going to claim
they're going to quit but what they're
more likely going to have to deal with
is i bet you he walks in there and he
says 50 of y'all are good performers 50
of y'all suck you're out and that's true
of every major business that would
happen at facebook that would happen in
all these different places
and so that's what i think is is uh
elon's magic here is he's gonna be able
to recruit the best talent in the world
and then just let them go he's not gonna
run twitter i also think uh there's two
other things to look at one is you
mentioned about the public markets
they've been public for a decade now and
shareholders have been screwed right
relative to not only the outperformance
of other equities real estate anything
else certainly bitcoin and other things
also
but relative to even just inflation
they've underperformed so the
shareholders are the only ones that have
really gotten screwed right the business
hasn't produced any meaningful return
for them so i think that's one part of
it that now they're going to have
someone in charge who's going to change
things up and can hopefully uh it well
actually if he's going to take a private
then they're going to get a a premium on
their share price as of today but
outside of that when you think of
everything that elon musk is working on
he never looks for like small
improvements to a process right or small
things right it's never 10 or 15 or 20
percent he's looking for 100x
improvements right how can i change an
entire industry how can i change the way
that we live how can i change the way
that we interact and all of those things
so for me it'd be really shocking and
surprising to see him come in buy
twitter let someone else run it and just
be like okay just fix the bots fix this
like let's grow incrementally here here
and here and just defend the free speech
like i just don't think that's the way
he operates because when you think about
how he's been able to not only build his
wealth but become so famous and make so
many life-changing businesses and
products he looked for these 100x ideas
right where you come in and not only is
no one competing against you like
literally he just has no competition
because people aren't going out and
building these rockets people aren't
going to build these electric vehicles
back when you've started doing it and so
forth so your competition's super
limited but the upside is much greater
also right so if you fail you fail right
twitter's still where it is today
ultimately but he also has the
opportunity to create something much
bigger than his then is there today hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time